also a new coronavirus test site a  drive-through test site that opens today  at texas station the testing started at  eight o'clock this morning it'll go  until  four this afternoon happening on the  first floor of the parking garage  on the south side of the texas station  property on rancho all to address  growing covered numbers  we are still suffering from this  pandemic  that the number of cases  again are going up in our community  for the last four five weeks we have  been  witnessing an increase in the number of  daily cases reported here  which means that we need to  to increase our efforts  texas station that operation will go on  a first come first serve basis you don't  need an appointment but  you should probably pre-register with  the health district first  to try and cut back on long lines